If you were to ask someone to name a famous
nurse, there’s an extremely high chance
they’d respond with the name of one 19th
Century woman.
Florence Nightingale is almost the archetype
of nurses.
A wealthy woman who gave it all up to devote
herself to caring for the sick, she’s still
pictured today as she was during her heyday
in the Crimean War, carrying a lamp from sickbed
to sickbed, tending to the wounded.
But how many of us know the woman behind the
myth?
Born into privilege in the early 19th Century,
Florence Nightingale was a polymath genius
who spoke multiple languages and pioneered
concepts of statistical analysis still used
today.
A shy, devout Christian, she was a feminist
who thought women shouldn’t vote; a celebrity
who wished only to be forgotten; and a nurse
who oversaw a hospital with one of the highest
death rates in modern history.
A complex woman full of contradictions, this
is the life of Florence Nightingale.
A Woman’s Place
What words spring to mind when you hear the
name Florence Nightingale?
We’re guessing it’s something along the
lines of ‘nurse’, ‘angel’, and possibly
‘lamp’.
What probably don’t spring to mind are words
like ‘borderline genius’.
Born on May 12, 1820 to English parents in
the city of Florence –no prizes for guessing
where she got her name from – Florence Nightingale
had the sort of brain that only comes along
once in a generation.
Her parents were super-connected, super-wealthy
English socialites who valued education, even
for their two daughters.
This was sort of a big deal at the time, when
being born with two X chromosomes was the
quickest shortcut to a life of knitting, wearing
corsets, and fainting whenever someone mentioned
long division.
Luckily for baby Florence, her father had
always dreamed of passing on his own Cambridge
education to his children, and he’d be damned
if he was going to let those children being
female from stopping him.
There’s actually some evidence Papa Nightingale
had expected Florence to be a boy and refused
to accept reality.
He encouraged the villagers on his estates
to refer to the young girl by the male title
“squire”.
Regardless, Florence’s early life was spent
in a blitz of learning that would leave an
honor student’s head spinning.
She mastered French, German, Greek, Italian
and Latin.
She memorized works of philosophy and would
debate them with her father.
She also got super into math, to the extent
that she begged her parents to let her go
and study the subject at university.
Her mother told her no.
It was not long after that Florence had her
vision.
We need to be careful with the word “vision”,
because it conjures, well, visions of people
like Joan of Arc communicating directly with
God.
Florence’s vision wasn’t like that.
It was more a feeling than anything, a certainty
that God had given her a silent command.
Still, the effect was dramatic.
On February 5, 1837, the sixteen year old
Florence declared God had told her to end
suffering in the world.
She interpreted this to mean she should go
into nursing.
This time, her mom and pop both told her no.
In those days, nursing was considered barely
above prostitution.
The idea that an upper-middle class girl would
go into the profession was so radical even
Florence’s liberal father refused to consider
it.
But if mom and pop thought they could keep
Florence from her calling, they had another
thing coming.
Over the next 13 years, Florence tried again
and again to change her parents’ minds.
In 1844, Florence tried, and failed, to convince
her parents to send her for nurse training
in Salisbury.
In 1849, she even ditched a long-term suitor,
Richard Monckton Milnes, so she could focus
on her non-existent career.
Random aside: it later transpired that this
suitor was heavily into sadomasochism, so
maybe actually kinda dodged a bullet there?
Anyway, Florence was persistent.
She kept working away at her parents all the
way from her teenage years, right into womanhood.
By the time 1850 rolled around, she was 30
and her father was utterly worn down.
That July, her parents gave her permission
to travel to Germany for a two week training
course at a nursing hospital.
Perhaps they thought being up close with all
that disease would put her off nursing for
life.
But, no.
The next year, Florence returned for another
course, this one lasting three months.
By 1853, Florence’s dream had been realized.
Using her family connections, she got a job
at a hospital for “distressed gentlewomen”
on Harley Street in London.
It wasn’t hugely taxing, but it was definitely
nursing.
Finally, Florence Nightingale had made it!
But it would soon transpire that this was
just the warm up act.
Florence Nightingale didn’t know it yet,
but she was about to get sucked into one of
the bloodiest conflicts in European history.
The Sick Man of Europe
In 1853, the European continent was haunted
by the specter of a sick man.
The Ottoman Empire had once been one of the
finest empires history ever produced.
At its height, it was an epicenter of science
and art capable of taking territory all the
way up into Austria.
By 1853, though, the glory days were over.
Hobbled by stagnation, secession, and wars
of independence, the Ottoman Empire was by
now staggering on the fringes of geo-politics,
known as “the sick man of Europe”.
As the invalid empire hacked away on its deathbed,
another empire sensed an opportunity.
In the Russian capital, it was lost on absolutely
no-one that a dying Ottoman state meant a
chance to snatch territory from the empire’s
fringes.
At the same time, in Paris and London, it
was lost on absolutely no-one that a territory-hungry
Russia posed a real threat to them all.
In October 1853, all these different strands
finally came together.
Under a pretext of defending Orthodox Christians
living in the sick empire, Russia made its
move.
The Turks declared war, which pulled in Britain
and France and suddenly the area around the
Black Sea was alight with conflict.
It was the start of the Crimean War, and it
would end somewhere in the region of a million
lives.
We could easily spend the next 20 minutes
describing this complex, forgotten war, but
for our purposes today, there are two things
you need to understand about the Crimean War.
The first is that this was the first war in
which the modern media was involved.
The first war correspondent in history, William
Howard Russell, was there for the Times of
London, sending back real-time reports via
the newly-invented telegraph.
The second is that military hospitals were
very different from what we’d expect now.
Nursing soldiers during wartime wasn’t something
governments did.
Since medieval times, it had usually been
religious orders like the Sisters of Mercy
who took care of the wounded.
When the Crimean War erupted, though, the
British government was so against the idea
of sending women into a conflict zone that
they actually forbid any nurses from going.
This meant the injured British troops were
receiving a level of care that was so basic,
you could program computers with it.
Yep, that was a terrible coding pun, and no,
we’re not sorry.
The upshot is that these two points overlapped
when William Howard Russell decided to write
about British military hospitals in Crimea,
and sent back reports so graphic they caused
outrage.
Caught back-footed, the British government
quickly reversed its “no nurses on the frontlines”
policy.
Suddenly, Secretary of State at War Sidney
Herbert found himself in dire need of a head
nurse to send to Crimea.
Luckily, he had just the woman in mind.
Many years earlier, in the 1840s, Herbert
and his wife Elizabeth had been visiting Rome
when they happened to bump into a vacationing
Florence Nightingale.
The three hit it off, and remained close friends
when they returned to England.
So it was, in 1854, that Herbert was able
to write to Nightingale and ask her to go
to Crimea.
Rather than saying “You want me to walk
unarmed into a slaughterhouse?
Gee, thanks,” Florence Nightingale jumped
at the chance.
Put at the head of 38 volunteer nurses, the
37 year old left behind her hospital for gentlewomen
and got on a boat on October 21, 1854.
It was meant to be a dream come true, a chance
to show her parents what she was really capable
of.
Instead, Florence Nightingale would soon find
herself trapped at the center of a nightmare.
“The Kingdom of Hell”
On November 5, 1854, Florence Nightingale
and her corps of nurses arrived at the British
military hospital in Scutari – today a suburb
of Istanbul.
What they found there would haunt them for
the rest of their lives.
The hospital was built atop a sewer, which
had flooded long ago and no-one had bothered
to plug.
When injured men walked to the toilets, they
had to pass barefoot through a layer of ankle
deep feces.
There were rodents running amok.
Men lying in filthy bedclothes that hadn’t
been changed for weeks on end.
There was rotting meat lying around from where
patients were supposed to cook their own meals.
People with unwashed, gangrenous wounds.
It was a human cesspit, a place where pestilence
and disease roamed the hallways, trailing
death in their wake.
The shock was so great that, for the first
few days, it was all Florence Nightingale
could do to keep functioning.
The military brass made it clear after she
landed that they didn’t want her rocking
their stinky, disease-ridden boat.
So she tried not to.
Really, she did.
This became tricky after November 10.
On that day, the British wounded of two major
battles arrived in Scutari.
The hospital, already in dire need of supplies,
effectively ran out.
It was during this time, when she was surrounded
by squalor and misery, and the screams of
the dying, that Nightingale famously called
her new hospital “the Kingdom of Hell.”
But the experience gave her the kick up the
rear she needed to get moving.
Remember how we said Florence Nightingale
was super into math as a teenager?
Well, she started crunching the numbers for
the hospital.
To her amazement, she discovered that war
injuries had killed around 4,000 people in
the hospital that year.
Sickness, on the other hand, had killed 19,000.
This wasn’t a hospital.
It was a charnel house.
Soldiers were coming in with treatable injuries
and leaving in coffins.
Faced with an army determined to keep doing
things the old way, Nightingale had no choice
but to start trying to save those soldiers
herself.
This is the part where we get to the legendary
image of Florence Nightingale, the nurse walking
the wards after dark, armed only with her
lamp, offering succor to the dying.
Certainly, this happened.
Nightingale’s nighttime visits became a
fixture of the wounded men’s lives.
But, really, this romanticized image is just
a sideshow.
The important stuff was happening behind closed
doors.
In meetings with army officers, Nightingale
insisted on basic standards of cleanliness
at Scutari, including regular bathing of patients,
and changing bandages on wounds.
At the same time, she campaigned for the open
sewer flooding the lower floors to be repaired,
something we’re having trouble believing
she actually needed to “campaign” for.
Of course, cleanliness and closing sewers
doesn’t make good copy, so the newspapers
that wrote about “the lady with the lamp”
focused more on her bedside manner.
There were the tales of Florence Nightingale
helping the wounded write letters home.
Of the night time visits she made to keep
the men’s spirits up.
Incidentally, the reason Nightingale was the
only one to visit the wards at night was because
the other nurses were forbidden to.
Nightingale thought they would have sex with
the male patients, so banned everyone else
from roaming around after dark.
Just a weird historical fact we couldn’t
fit in elsewhere.
Before long, the men at Scutari had grown
to love their “ministering angel”, and
the British public had grown to love her,
too.
That’s right, Nightingale became a celebrity.
The tales of her selfless good work were exactly
what Britain needed from a war that had so
far produced no heroes.
This reached its apex on February 24, 1855.
That day, a London newspaper published an
engraving of Nightingale with her lamp.
Overnight, this random nurse working in a
British military hospital became more than
just a woman.
She became a symbol.
The days of Florence Nightingale, the human,
were over.
The days of Florence Nightingale, the lady
with
the lamp, had arrived.
The Lady with
the Lamp
Today, the truth of Florence Nightingale has
almost been lost to the myths swirling around
her name; both good and bad.
For example, you’ve maybe heard how Scutari
actually had a higher death rate under Nightingale,
whose reforms were more often than not fatal
for patients.
This is a tale that’s cropped up before
on places as venerable as the BBC.
It’s also likely complete bull poop.
Actual Nightingale scholars like Mark Bostridge
are adamant this is based on a misreading
of the data – sort of like how you might
look at the way WWII combat deaths spiked
after September, 1939, and conclude Winston
Churchill was the bad guy.
Yes, deaths at Scutari jumped under Nightingale.
But that’s because she arrived just as supplies
ran out and the hospital exceeded capacity.
That’s not to say the lady with the lamp
was always a saint.
The same time that Nightingale was at Scutari,
around 1855, a British commission looking
into sanitation proposed similar hospital
reforms to hers.
To this day, some think Nightingale effectively
stole their ideas and passed them off as her
own.
Then there’s the issue of Mary Seacole.
A half-Jamaican “doctress” who used herbal
remedies, Seacole traveled to the Crimea under
her own steam and set up a hospital on the
peninsula to treat sickened officers.
She and Nightingale were aware of one another,
and didn’t like each other very much.
There’s some evidence Nightingale may have
refused to let Seacole join her nursing corps
due to her race.
On the other hand, suggestions that Nightingale
took credit for Seacole’s innovations don’t
seem to have much grounding in historical
sources.
Come 1855, Nightingale was a hero of the British
Empire.
Back in London, a fund had been set up in
her name that would eventually raise £45,000,
equivalent to a really, really big pile of
cash in today’s money.
The nurse had also won respect for getting
her hands dirty.
On a trip to Crimea itself, she’d been badly
sickened and nearly died.
While the papers celebrated her recovery,
no-one knew she’d picked up brucellosis,
a recurring infection that would soon leave
her badly disabled.
But that was all in the future.
Until the war ended, all Florence Nightingale
wanted to focus on was caring for her patients.
On March 30, 1856, end it finally did.
The Treaty of Paris was the end of the Crimean
War, a mass slaughter that had killed a million
but changed very little.
Those million that had died, by the way?
Almost all of them were carried off by disease.
After the war wrapped, Nightingale stayed
on in Scutari to help close the hospital,
before finally departing herself.
On August 7, 1856, she arrived back in Britain
to a hero’s welcome.
Seriously.
People were treating her like the second coming
of Elvis… and Nightingale absolutely hated
it.
As she saw it, the hysteria over the Lady
with the Lamp was just a way of distracting
from the real issues: the reform the army
medical establishment desperately needed.
In the end, she decided she’d just have
to push through these reforms herself.
In Sickness and…
In the mid-19th Century, if you got sick,
there was only one explanation: miasma.
Miasma theory was one of those things you
sometimes hear about in history that sound
so screwy you almost can’t believe people
actually thought it was real.
Basically, people thought that diseases were
caused by bad smells.
The cholera you might contract from raw sewage?
That wasn’t because of germs, but because
of the smell of poop.
Not long before the Crimean War, miasma theory
had become so widely accepted that the British
government actually approved a plan to drain
sewage into drinking water, because that would
be less harmful than letting it pong on the
surface.
Yuck.
By the time Florence Nightingale came along,
miasma wasn’t the only theory in town.
Many medical professionals were sounding alarm
bells that maybe this new germ theory was
where it’s at.
But miasma was still the theory British politicians
and army medical brass believed.
And Florence Nightingale was about to explode
all that as effectively as a stack of dynamite.
After her return home, Nightingale devoted
all her energy and intellect to getting a
Royal Commission established to look into
preventable deaths in the Crimean War.
But the army stonewalled her.
So Nightingale teamed up with government statistician
William Barr to provide evidence that something
needed to be done.
In 1856, statistical analysis was at the cutting
edge of modern science.
All those lovely, easy-to-understand charts
you see on Nate Silver’s blogs didn’t
exist yet.
The fact they do is in part thanks to Nightingale
and Barr.
For roughly a year, the two worked to crunch
the data by hand.
They compared the records of the hospital
at Scutari to a London military hospital,
and then also a Manchester civilian hospital
as a control.
As the excellent Bedside Rounds podcast details
– and, really, their episode on Florence
Nightingale is a great resource for understanding
her statistical breakthroughs – miasma theory
suggested the hospital in Manchester should
be the worst of all.
Manchester in 1856 was a choking, billowing
cauldron of stench.
It was everything miasma believers feared.
But Nightingale and Barr’s data showed something
very different.
The death rates in the Manchester civilian
hospital were far below those in the London
military one.
While the death rate in Scutari had initially
outpaced even the London hospital, after Nightingale’s
reforms, it had dropped into second place.
A military hospital in the civilized British
capital had a higher death rate than a field
hospital on the edges of an active warzone.
As Nightingale put it, sanitation in British
army hospitals was so bad, it was akin to
taking 1,100 young men out onto Salisbury
Plain each year and shooting them dead.
When Nightingale and Barr presented their
findings, they did so visually, using what
we’d now call a coxcomb graph.
It’s said that this was likely one of the
first times in history data was presented
visually.
That made it easier to understand.
When the government saw her graphs, Nightingale
was vindicated.
A major review of army medical standards was
undertaken with sweeping effect.
The reforms the lady with the lamp had first
started all the way back in Scutari were implemented
across the board, including methods for cataloguing
disease and death rates that were still in
use well into the 20th Century.
By the time the British Army intervened in
China’s bloody Taiping Rebellion in the
early 1860s, Florence Nightingale’s recommendations
had so taken root that the death rate for
soldiers from disease was 90% lower than it
had been in the Crimean War.
For Nightingale, this was a major triumph.
The last half decade of her life had been
consumed with forcing army medical culture
to change, and now here she was directing
those changes.
But there would be no time for celebration.
In 1857, Nightingale suffered her first collapse
due to the brucellosis infection she’d picked
up in Crimea.
In no time at all, the disease had emaciated
her.
She lost her hair, lost weight, became effectively
bedridden, often suffering pain so acute she
was unable to work.
For the rest of her life, Britain’s most
famous nurse would live in agony.
The Body Declines
From a physical standpoint, that was pretty
much it for Nightingale.
After coming down with her illness, she retreated
to bed and never really left.
But while she’d never again go as far away
as Crimea, the polymath nurse wasn’t done
yet.
She was just getting started.
Confined to her bed, Nightingale started writing
letters.
Hundreds of them.
Thousands of them.
Campaigning letters going out to all corners
of the country, outlining the need for major
medical reforms.
And that’s not all she did.
Remember how people in Britain raised £45,000
for her while she was in Scutari?
Well, Nightingale took that money, and used
it to found a secular nursing school at St
Thomas’s Hospital, London.
The Nightingale School wasn’t the first
nursing school in Britain.
But it was the first that fulfilled three
strict criteria.
One: it was secular.
Two: it developed its program in line with
scientific advances.
And, three: it treated nursing as a career.
No longer would nursing be something for nuns
and the lower classes.
Nightingale wanted to make nursing a legitimate
profession.
You can see she succeeded just by looking
around you today.
Nowadays, those who see nursing as synonymous
with prostitution are strictly stupid, horny
men with a tragic thing for uniforms.
But this is where it all started.
Nightingale’s school was the first to give
nurses good pay, sick leave, annual vacation.
Perhaps most importantly, though, the school
encouraged its nurses to travel.
To set up schools in other countries and pass
the message on.
Within a few years, Nightingale nurses had
fanned out across the British Isles.
A few years after that, they were establishing
schools in America.
A few years after that, they were even setting
up hospitals in Japan.
As they went, the Nightingale nurses took
some core tenets with them.
Nurses should be separate to doctors, rather
than merely subordinate.
They should enforce cleanliness and the washing
of wounds.
And healthcare should be available for everyone.
If you live in a nation with universal healthcare,
it may well be thanks in part to Florence
Nightingale.
From her bed, the great medical reformer tirelessly
advocated for equal treatment of the poor
by nurses and doctors.
It’s this belief that eventually evolved
into Britain’s modern NHS.
Of course, there was more to Nightingale’s
last years than just medicine.
She became the first female fellow of the
Royal Statistical Society.
She advocated for minority rights across the
British Empire.
She also wrote one of the key texts of 19th
Century feminism: Casandra, a book detailing
how intelligent women are often ignored by
less-intelligent men, which, wow, unfortunately
still seems pretty relevant.
But perhaps the most interesting thing about
Florence Nightingale’s later life is how
private it was.
Famously prickly, the now-elderly lady with
the lamp hated receiving visitors, hated having
her picture taken, hated being reminded of
her fame.
Towards the end of her life, she declared
“I only want to be forgotten,” and changed
her will to stipulate she shouldn’t have
a public funeral.
Finally, on August 13, 1910, the 90-year old
Nightingale breathed her last.
For the British public, it was like a symbol
of the nation had been lost.
Despite her pleas for a private funeral, people
lined the road all the way to Nightingale’s
final resting place.
Government ministers made speeches at a special
service at St Paul’s cathedral.
Although Nightingale had specified that she
wanted to be buried in an anonymous, unmarked
grave, she was finally put to rest beneath
a headstone bearing her name at St Margaret’s
Church.
Today, the legend of Florence Nightingale
is still going strong.
She’s endured as a symbol in a way few ever
will.
Every year, nurses still carry lighted lamps
into Westminster Abbey in London, to mark
the passing of the lady with the lamp.
It’s a touching ritual.
Poignant.
It’s also something Miss Nightingale probably
would have hated.
Florence Nightingale didn’t want to be remembered.
She didn’t want to have lamplight processions
and YouTube videos about her life.
She simply wanted to vanish.
To be anonymous.
But, sometimes, someone lives a life so great
that forgetting them simply isn’t an option.
When Florence Nightingale was born, women
were considered incapable of understanding
concepts like statistics.
Nursing was considered unsuitable for middle
class girls.
Being healthy meant not sniffing smelly air.
The fact that Florence Nightingale was able
to not just challenge all of these assumptions,
but help overturn them explains why she’s
remembered today.
Born into a world with a glass ceiling so
low it was practically a cage, Nightingale
managed to smash through and, in doing so,
change the world.
She may have been a living legend who wished
to be forgotten, but she was also something
else.
A symbol for both the wounded and the dying,
and those who wished to tend for them.
She was, if nothing else, the Lady with
the Lamp.